ein kleiner park im moskauer viertel
konserve es ist kalt an diesem abend es
regnet ungemütlich sergej tatar ins heft
schlendert mit seiner nachbarin euler
vom häuserblock aus in den park an den
leinen ein mischling ein collie und ein
knapp zwei jahre alter puma ich war sehr
lange hundehalter aber der ganze dreck
die haare überall
ich habe dann beschlossen mir eine katze
zuzulegen und ich wollte eine große
katze ehrlich mir geht etwas die düse
ich bin deutlich nervöser als herkules
immerhin die katze bringt 60 kilo
kampfgewicht auf die waage eigentlich
aber ist er ganz lieb sagt sergej wie
ist das eigentlich so ein tier mitten in
der stadt gibt es da probleme
hercules ist das überhaupt kein problem
dass er mitten in der stadt lebt es gibt
doch genug platz für auslauf für hunde
und vier katzen
was sergej so entspannt beschreibt ist
eine groteske nächtliche szenerie auf
dem bolzplatz nebenan wird gekickt
niemand weiß dass ein paar meter
entfernt ein raubtier an einer
hundeleine gassi geht und dann treffen
wir nachbarin mit ihrem mischling wieder
mischling einer hat glück herkules
verbeißt sich nur in sein hinterteil
verspielt ist er halt könnte man meinen
aber herkules ist eine waffe das wird in
diesem moment mehr als deutlich
sowas kann vorkommen weil ja tut mir
leid nicht so schlimm kann eben alles
mögliche passieren mit so einem tier mit
dem großen und gibt es nie probleme
[Musik]
russlands werde wohnzimmer bewohner es
ist nach wie vor ein echter trend das
zusammenleben mit wilden tieren warum
machen die so was und warum ist das
erlaubt so einfach ist das nicht aber
dazu später mehr
das ist cesar 1 70 kilo schwerer leopard
sein herrchen alex volkov muss ihn zur
räson bringen cesar hat keinen guten tag
in die nase das ist die
erziehungsmethoden keine ausgeprägte
gewalt dem tier tut das nicht weh aber
es ist ihm sehr unangenehm cesar muss
funktionieren und ex fallschirmspringer
alex volkov weiß dass sein job heute
besonders sensibel ist kenia steht die
angst ins gesicht geschrieben aber ihre
mama will die fotos mit der katze auf
social media sorgen sie für anerkennung
und zuspruch
das ist ein ganz besonderes erlebnis
eine erinnerung für das ganze leben
deshalb habe ich meine tochter
hergebracht
leoparden stehen auf der roten liste
sind vom aussterben bedroht wie viele
tierarten die in russland als haustiere
gehalten werden
ich gebe zu dass in russland solche
tiere ausgebreitet werden vor allem
junge die löwen oder tiger babys bei
tesa sei das anders sagt die fotografin
alex kümmere sich gut um ihn er sei für
ihn ein echter lebensgefährte ich habe
lange in der armee gedient brauche
seitdem einen nervenkitzel und wird mir
langweilig ein leben ohne risiko und
adrenalin ist für mich nicht mehr
vorstellbar aber alex wolf lebt davon
sein wildes haustier in ganz russland
zur schau zu stellen er verdient gut
daran wie viel darüber schweigt er
tierschützer nennen das foto sklaverei
potter bridge und mische heißen die
braunbären die hier ihre kräfte messen
mischer rechts war mal ein haustier man
glaubt es kaum potter politisch links
hat eine besondere geschichte gelandet
ist er in der auffangstation von
alexander fjodorow bei sankt petersburg
ist der einzige bär der selbst zu den
menschen gekommen ist in der region
gacina ist er auf eine baustelle
marschiert und in einen wohnwagen
eingezogen er hat dort drei tage gelebt
und das ganze dorf hat ihn gefüttert
öfter aber sind fjodorow kunden tiere
die aus privatbesitz gerettet werden
oder die verstoßen wurden 150 von ihnen
haben hier ein halbwegs artgerechtes
zuhause gefunden
menschen die wilde tiere zu hause
erhalten blieben nicht die tiere
sie nehmen sich selbst du kannst ein
tier nicht lieben und es dazu zwingen in
einer engen wohnung zu leben
niemand weiß genau wie viele wildtiere
in privaten wohnungen in russland leben
seit einer gesetzesänderung im
vergangenen jahr ist das verboten wer
aber vorher einen löwen im wohnzimmer
hatte durfte ihn behalten
der tierschutz hat keine große lobby im
land
das zeigt auch diese geschichte aus
moskau aus der vorvergangenen woche
die polizei liefert sich einen
stundenlangen schusswechsel mit dem
besitzer einer villa
der mann betreibt einen illegalen
waffenhandel die polizisten feuer an
eine granate ins haus
die villa geht in flammen auf als die
beamten stürmen finden sie die leiche
des hausherrn im montreux und im
innenhof einen privatzoo inklusive eines
tigers und eines braunbären
die liebe zum wilden tier sie wird
geteilt von extrovertierten kriminellen
wohlhabenden normalos auch sergej tatar
in sap empfindet diese liebe und seine
ist gerade ein teenager sozusagen
hercules and noch keinen ausgeprägten
charakter
er ist gerade in der pubertät und bald
geschlechter dass in dieser phase auch
der jagdtrieb wächst macht sergej nicht
nachdenklich mut so scheint es gehört
dazu zum zusammenleben mit zu einer
katze und hercules an diesem abend ist
er ruhig lässt sich nicht ablenken
hoffen wir für sergej und alle moskauer
das ist so bleibt
[Musik]